[موسيقى]
إنه لأمر صادم لأنني لم آكلني في البداية.
كانت هناك صدمة كافية لتشغيل احتياطي الجسم
[موسيقى]
يا
غالبًا ما يشار إلى Funazushi على أنه جذور السوشي.
أمامنا 1 استعارة سوشي ، اسمي ماريكو كيتامورا
أنا أصنع السوشي مع زوجي
لأن طعمه فريد من نوعه ، فإن نسخة السمك من بروسكيوتو والملوحة هي 9
أعتقد أنه مثل الكافيار
إيه
يمكن تقسيم السوشي تقريبًا إلى نوعين ، مثل هذا ومثال مبكر.
سيكون السوشي العام سريعًا ، لذا إذا كسرت الأرز ووضعت المادة على الأرز
يمكنني أكله في يوم آخر
في حالة Funazushi ، سيكون كتابًا
وبالتالي
إنه طعام محفوظ مصنوع عن طريق تخمير سفينة من بحيرة بيوا بالأرز.
سيكون هذا طبقًا محليًا لمحافظة شيغا
تم إنشاء المتجر قبل 400 عام في عام 1619. أنا الجيل الثامن عشر من بادي
إنه أمر مزعج للغاية ، ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر بتصميم هذا الزي ،
أنا أيضًا أحب الأشياء المزعجة حقًا
فيما يلي بعض الأشياء المهمة عن Sister Princess
أنا أسحب الصدارة
إذا قمت بهذه المهام الثلاث ، فلن يكون الأمر لذيذًا.
[موسيقى]
Funazushi من الحالة الخام
يستغرق فقدان المنتج حوالي 3 أشخاص
لأنه يستغرق وقتًا وجهدًا مجانًا
عدد المنازل التي تكتب مثل الأيام الخوالي آخذ في التناقص.
ثقافة الطعام في محافظة شيغا
لأنه يقال ، يمكننا فقط أن نجعلها
(أ) أريد أن يعرف الجميع جذور سوشي فونازوشي.
إنه لذيذ فقط
تصبح مسببة للإدمان
[موسيقى]